thank you very much for inviting me to
speak here
uh i will speak about this joint work
with joseph and veronica my wife
and uh since this is all recorded i
should better mention that uh this is
work support this work is supported was
supported by european commission
foundation for polish science and my
co-authors were supported by polish
minister and
nsf and
i would start with
defining the
four notions that i have over there and
then i will explain um
the notions that i'm using in the
definitions
so first of all i will work with a
variety
in some in some productive space
and if you
are if you want you can think that x is
really uh
veronese variety
a variety of some other vector space
inside
projectivization of the symmetric
tensor power of this and this is just
the set of simple tensors
simple symmetric sensors
or you can think of secret variety
with three factors if you if you want or
you can take more factors
inside the projectivization of eight
answer b
c
also the set of simple tensors here
the objects which were
showing up here
a bunch of times already
and i would like to
define the
the rank the border rank this is these
are the notions that you probably
already
have seen and then the other ranks as
well
so the rank
x rank of a point
point is always
in the projective space pw
it's just the
minimum r
that
is in the linear span of
some subset r
where
r is a finite subset
so in case of the varanesa variety we
just get warring crank that envico told
us about yesterday and other peoples as
well people as well and in the case of
uh
segregated variety we got the tensor
rank and the other usual options in the
other cases if you are familiar with
them
and then
the border ranks
and the border rank x border rank of p
is
equal to the minimum
r
e is
well
in the limit
of
rd
where
rt is a family of
well at least continuous family of
subsets of
of eggs
again enough length each of the length
lengths are
right so this was the easy part this was
the easy part now i should explain the
uh the more difficult stuff and that's
um
it will take me some time so let me just
write the definition first and then i
will explain the notions appearing in
the definitions
so the characters rank
i released it in a different order so
let me leave some space
cactus rank
is the minimum
again the same
the same
pattern as above except that i'm
changing a little bit my object
so this is the minimum r such that p is
in the linear span of r
now my r
in x
is
the finite
sub skin
x
of length
r
and they want the
middle motion x
suitable rank of b
is the minimum
r such that
this
in the linear span of r
and
r in x
is a finite
smooth
sub
scheme of length r
right um
so
okay give me a little bit of time before
i start explaining this i i will just
let you
imagine why these notions are
important and why they are
why we are interested in studying them
at all
so
first of all there is a bunch of
inequalities between these notions
we have rung is
always the largest integer
and then we have
we might have
this integer to be
less than
more than disposable rank of b
which is always
this but it's always
more than the border rank
and then this one is
northern characters rank of b okay
so why do we have this well
first of all
each set finite set set of points
really is a smooth scheme and it has
length r
well it's actually smooth scheme so it
doesn't need smoothing that's
something we will
i will just try to explain
and
um
so therefore this minimum is certainly
less than this minimum because we allow
more objects here
next for to compare with the co with the
cactus rank
uh we
just hear the difference between these
two notions is just this
smooth ability
and
that's
just i forget here going from here to
here i just forget one condition so
again this is a bigger bigger set
which is why
this rank is less
next the border rank
well this vulnerability is exactly
chosen in such a way to squeeze between
rank and the
border rank
and this
exactly means that our r is a limit in
some sense of
a distinct point
which is why it it lives here
but unfortunately
all the other
inequalities which you could write
between these numbers
might be false
for some conditions well
some people suggest to
add one more
this border cactus rank
so i will not talk about this rank it's
i don't know if it has any significant
applications so far so
i will skip this one okay and why why we
are interested in these two
new objects well for applications these
guys are the main
ones that we can
we can understand and we can use whereas
these two are those that we usually see
although
mainly this one
it's
rather difficult to produce conditions
on
on the border rank which are not
satisfied by the cactus rank as well
and that's why
we want to understand the difference
between these
these two notions
okay and in my talk at the end i would
try to present you examples where
border rank
is
less than cactus rank
and then
in alessandra stock you will see
examples where the border rank
is
more than cut to struck
some one of these should be strict right
to make it
thank you
and
in my example actually this will be
equal to the rank
which is which also shows the
failure
to
of this to be an
equality
okay
so i should explain the notion of finite
scheme so in general schemes in
algebraic geometry might you might you
may think they are difficult for some
reason but finite scheme or
finite schemes are really easy so we
already have seen an example of a finite
scheme
this joint union of
points
and some
in projective space or in x
then this is a finite scheme of like an
example of finite scheme
of length r
and
if
on the other hand we can look at this
finite
at this finite set as
as
functions from
our
complex numbers
today i'm working on more complex
numbers to make some statements easier
it's not entirely necessary but it helps
a little bit
i can look at finite functions from r to
c
well
and that's
just
um
justice just of what
an algebra but it's very simple algebra
it's just c plus c plus
c
r times
and the idea behind schemes is to allow
object geometric objects which have more
complicated algebras of functions
let me stick to examples first and then
i will try to formalize this
so for example if you want to
know about
if we have a function from
or an open subset of x
through the complex numbers
and we have
this sub-scheme here or subset subset
here
if we want to know the values of the of
this function
at
points p1
and say
f
prime of p2 so the first derivative of
of f at
p2
and for this we need to know
uh well at least
dimension of x
plus two
uh values
some expansions of f
right f prime of p2 you mean the full
differential
yes specific directional derivative
sorry this is in this example
for this thing we need dimension
unless an effect is smooth
but it's not really necessary but for
just for simplicity representation
we need dimension of x values for this
thing
and then one for
for this guy and one
for this
so all together this scheme is going to
be be what's
um
in this case r will be
just a single point p one
and a double point
supported
what does it mean well this means that
for the algebra functions
as here i should take
c for value of p1 and then the more
complicated algebra here
which is actually
isomorphic to c of the polynomial
algebra
dimension of x variables divided by all
the by the idea generated by
x i x j
so i'm not interested in higher
derivatives that's why i'm getting
square expressions i'm only interested
in linear derivatives which is why i'm
i'm preserving the
first
the first grading of this
this as you can see it's a finite
algebra
which is
um isomorphic to
as a vector space is just
n plus one
it has information
about the value of of a function about
what
uh at the point and about all its
derivatives
and similarly you can ask for higher
derivatives of f and higher
or just directional derivatives and
there are many
examples that you can see in this way
so formally
like them
i don't want
you saying p1 is not equal to p2 is that
the question
so then the
all defined by square of the maximal
idea
uh okay so formally
finite scheme i should say
the german is the geometric
interpretation
for the
for finite
algebras
finite algebra
r
and now if we can write this or as a
direct sum of
okay
and each of those factors will
correspond to a different point of
support of this
of the scheme so the scheme will be
supported at this k point
and has length
which is the sum
of
dimensions
complex dimensions
of o r
i
which is just the complex dimension of
okay and
this presentation you need
this one after reordering yes
okay
so now why why these guys are useful to
us
so the point is that we can look so this
is just an ups the definition of an
abstract scheme so it doesn't have to be
leave anywhere but we really want to we
are really interested in sub schemes
so we say that
r is a sub scheme of x
if we can
well if we should be able to to relate
this algebras
to
the to the structure of x
and we can look at functions
well we should better have some
structure
on
x
perhaps
defined locally in some neighborhood
it's an open subset and we should be
able to restrict those functions
r
and well we the functions should have
some
always have some multiplicative
structure so we can take two functions
and multiply them and after restrictions
you can like the restriction you can
multiply them in this algebra and you
want these two multiplications to agree
so the restriction of the multiplication
must be equal to
multiplication of the restriction
let me just give another example
if we have
we can look at
x inside
for simplicity alpha into space or
sits inside the projective two space
and this is just
for a parabola so
x equals
y square
and
inside here
we can look
this is at the sub scheme of length
three
we will
we want it to be supported at zero zero
and isomorphic too
um
the scheme determined by algebra
dft divided by t cube
okay this should determine the scheme
so if we think of it as as as a
sub-scheme of this parabola it will give
us the information about
third order
functions
up to up to well up to order two of the
functions in
in the on the parabola so
parabola is isomorphic to
to a line telephone line
and
it's
just if i have a function on their fine
line and i restrict it to this scheme r
then restricted to r
is
giving us
the information about the value of f at
zero
about the first derivative at zero and
about the second derivative at zero
while
um
but
it's also embedded in the alpha into
space
as if we have
a function g
from the alpha into space to
complex numbers and it should give us
information about
well also the value at zero but now only
about one derivative
g
g zero
zero
y i
guess double check this
and now well
you see this this is not any more
uh
little more straight line this is a
parabola so the
other way around i guess
so i have the information about this
derivative
but the other derivative is already
twisted it doesn't fit into this
curve so it's not really the derivative
in the direction of y anymore
but some linear combination of the
derivative
in the second in the
the second direct direction as well and
it's possible to calculate this
and
unfortunately i forgot to take my notes
i don't remember exactly
right so
all right so
our life would be much easier
if oh
yes
yes so it's so this o of r is also
isomorphic to
c of x and y
divided by
well the equation of
parabola and i should also have
equations let me guarantee that
the
eq piece
in the idl
which is
x y
y square
for some of them
yeah but if you homogenize then your
then you also need the other ones
okay
so there is one way of obtaining
schemes that's relevant to our
definitions which is
by limits
so if we have so as i said the starting
example was just union of
of finite points
and then we moved our five our
finite number of points
and some of them will collide
so there is a family
and all of a sudden some of them collide
and what we get in the limit we want it
to be in some sense continuous so we
should rather count the limiting
collision collision point with
multiplicity
there are two points
then this the limit point will have
multiplicity too
and if there are more points obviously
there this is this is going to be more
and then if uh
if
the
but there is also an extra structure not
only just number thus multiplicity but
we can say for example if
in which direction they have
from which direction they have collided
so for example if one point
was fixed and the other was coming from
some direction
then
we
at the end result we just get
the direction of the incoming point in
general it's kind of
an algebraic process to determine
exactly the structure of the limit but
it's always possible to do
and
there is a notion of
it's called flood limit
so if we have a family
now i should better assume that this is
algebraic
or at least holomorphic
also some base
t
which is flat
and
let me not explain what's flat what what
means it's essentially for finite
schemes it means that
all the fibers have the same length
this is
plus proper
properness which is kind of compactness
condition so i don't i don't want to
consider
a family
like
this is not a nice family although it's
a
you can define it algebraically right
because this
so
this part is just
x times y
equal one
this is some other
point whatever it is
and then this i i consider i would
consider the projection
onto the
base
this property takes care of this kind of
stupid examples
and
then if i have a flat family
such that it for
an open subset here
the image of this open subset consists
only of
smooth schemes so just disjoint points
so
what is the condition on the subset u
it's open substitute oh well actually
any non-empty sample
will be good enough because uh
to be at this joint point is an open
condition
of different points in open
you don't need to worry about
this
then
the limiting point so anything
and the
scheme
foreign
outside you
we say that
the fiber
rt
is dismissable
and that's the definition of the set of
smoothable schemes so
in brief words they are just limits of
disjoint
union of points
i'm not sure what you were what this
the logic of this definition i mean what
what
um sorry for that so that's
so the the the this should be the
formal language
to have an honest definition
and the formal language is as follows so
if we have a flat family of skins
which is
another bright family
finite schemes uh done so this is the
definition of smoothable yes this is the
difference
definition the scheme is smoothable if
it has this property if there exists
such such
and then there is
um
we i should be able to
i should explain also the linear span of
a scheme
if i have a scheme r
i should say what is the its linear span
and this is going to be
just well as usual linear span this is
the smallest linear subspace that
contains this scheme
now what does it mean that the linear
subspace contains this scheme let me not
give a formal definition instead i just
draw an example so if i have a scheme
which is which has information about the
first derivative in this direction
so i should
so it's not contained in the in just
zero dimensional schemes up in just zero
dimensional linear space supported at
this point but it's contained in this
line
similarly if i had this one this example
here
which had information about the
first derivative here
in this direction and then a little bit
twisted second derivative
then i can't contact have it contained
in signal line
i really need a plane for that
for the linear span of this
skin
is
is the
plane that contains the
parabola
yeah
so for smoothable ones it's okay for me
to just think of the limit of the
of the span of the r points or or is
that uh
that's the
that's the point so that's if i have a
family
so is the
dimension of the span of the scheme
always equal to its light there can it
be less
it can be life so let me just you give
their favorite example
this is a finite scheme if there are
three points on a line then their span
is
a line similarly
if you have a scheme
you have as well non-reduced well that's
a more complicated scheme it still can
have length three and be contained in a
single line
so the
it's true though that
if i have a family department tries
by t
and if
i take the limit
of the linear spans
on the other side i take the limit
of
rt and the linear span of this
then there is an inclusion going this
way
but not the other way not necessarily
the other way
and we would be very happy if this was
always equality
that's
if
equality always holds
then smoothable rank is equal
so we have to start to the border rank
okay so let me just give you a
class some classifications
so we have
if we
have any smooth variety x in a
projective space
then we can look at this the second
varieties
of x
which is
just
a set of points
in the projecting space such that
well
you can
define it in the various ways that the
rank of p
is at most
r
and then you take the closure
for example or you can just say this is
the set of points where the border rank
is at most two or you can replace the
rank by smoothable rank this all these
definitions will be will give you the
same
thing so let me just
then you still need to take the closure
or
if you don't want the closure you just
have to use the border
okay
r is equal to two
and we have a point in the
second variety
then
e is either equal
either
0
is in x
the case one is
the linear span of x and y for some x
and y
next and then the third case
e is in the linear span of a
point
of a point with single dungeon direction
which just means that x is uh that p is
in the
entrance space
at some point
and this is a classical theorem so in
this case we always have smoothable rank
so if r is if
the border rank is equal to two
then the smooth rank
is equal to the cactus rank
of p
and it's equal to
for this statement is a bit important
that's x is a smooth variety
and also the other
implications hold true okay but already
for r equals three in the interesting
cases we have
we have failure of this inequality
obviously sorry
r is equal to three
is a point in the third secant of x
and now we need to assume a little bit
about x but you can think it's
um
well
remember the examples that we started
from
and
well we can have p in the
second second variety which
which we just refer to the previous case
and the other cases well there is a
p in the linear span of x y z
x
there is point that's
in the linear span of a scheme
like that so there is
y and
the tangent direction
or we can have
a point in the linear span of a triple
scheme
degree 3 scheme or length 3 skin
like the one in the example
before
so this is point x
tangent direction
and then second order derivative
and therefore there is a fourth case
which doesn't show up in the varanasi
case but it does show up in the segger
case
that p is in the
in our span of
two tangent points
two schemes like this
so remember r was
three so we are in the third second
variety
but we are here taking two disjoint
schemes of length two all together they
have length four
and
but we also we require that x
x and y
are contained in a line
that's contained in x that's why it
doesn't show up in the baron as a
variety because there are no lines
contained
in
the variety
and that's all for these cases and
several more cases these are all the
possible
forms of the
points in the
in the third second variety
and
well
all these have smoothable rank
equal to the cactus rank equal to the
border rank
whereas this thing has smoothable rank
equal to
four
and the cactus rank
is also equal to four but the border
rank
is equal to three
well at least well for sufficiently
general point like this there would be
this this whole
again
it can be less but there are examples
where this is equal
and
then
another variety we also have similar
examples
but
uh we need to go to the fifth second
variety for that
so
if
r is less than 4
then
and x is everywhere
we always have
just
the border rank here and we always
portable rank
this equals the order rank
regardless rank
and
if r is equal four if r uh sorry is p4
is equal
five
then we can then there is an example
which is
x zero
cubic
zero squared
y zero plus x
2 plus
x 1 squared y 1
plus
x 1 2
x 1 x 1 squared
y 2.
this leaves in
s3
c5
and
like smooth rank
of x
class of x is equal to six whereas the
border rank is equal to five
and
well you can write well to prove to see
that this is uh
this has border rank five you just write
explicitly this
polynomial as a limit of five distinct
five
cubes
some of the five cubes
whereas it's a bit more complicated to
see this is not
that this holds well
it's easy to see that it's at most six
it's not so easy to see that it's
exactly there is some calculation too
excuse me
you can prove that also the rank is six
in this case
the rank
here the rank of this guy is
what has the here's the inequality with
the right
it's actually equal to nine which by
chance this is more than eight which is
generic
so
if you go to
higher degree do you have to go to
higher uh
border rank to get these kind of
examples exactly so if you you are you
well the minimum you have you need is
that
if you are looking at points in the
sd
and
to obtain
well let me just put it as a positive
statement if
the border rank
of c
is
equal it's at most
t plus one
then
i should also say that
this was a talk about the difference
between smoothable and border rank
but there are non-smoothable schemes
and they
produce difference between cactus rank
and smoothable rank which is a little
more delicate than this
thank you i'm sorry for taking cover
so could you get an idea of how you
improve the
um submittable rank is greater than the
quarter rank in that example
there's an example
well so
uh if so so this i i've said that i
didn't write it so this is true for
sufficiently general point of this type
and
well
it's not entirely trickle but we prove
it in our paper that the
points of this type
are not
the general point of this type is not of
one of the types above
well i mean this is a
yeah but so good okay so let me ask the
question differently smoothbowl does not
outbreak the closed condition
so
right that's why we have to take generic
one
that's the
so it becomes very delicate
yes well let me let me just do it again
so um
there is that we we can use the
classification of schemes of length
three at most three yes so these are
well this is this is one example so
three distinct points
there's one point and the time and the
double point or down on the left it's
not on the list yes
that's not a good thing
well it's a good proof in this sense
that it proves that your own
but we're going to run out of lists very
soon right uh right and then there is
algebra that comes to our hub
right so what kind of algebra do you use
okay so it's not algebraic property
which is not vocal
non-closed properties sorry right that's
why we use algebra not geometry
so the
um
well i mean i didn't say that but there
is an algebraic definition of the linear
spawn is just
that
if you have a sub scheme
of
a protective
face then there is an i that you can
define the ideal
of the functions that vanish on r that
is a
ideal in the
symmetric algebra
of w dual
and
you just look at the
linear span of our just the zero set of
the ideal
period
oh i see so
and then
you just look for for
while
callings so the length of skin
is just equal to the dimension complex
dimension
of
well
maybe that's
the
degree
of
the quotient algebra symmetry
so
now i'm starting to understand so this
kind of modification of what exactly did
in this
in this uh more general setting
and
if you have
well you just look for so if you have
length three in this case you just look
for
algebras which have this length
this this condition which is very
restrictive already and then you look at
this
degree one function that can show up in
this idea
i was wrong it's not
you're not looking at qualitative
properties about how it's situated
you're
that's looking else
yeah i'm looking at this too but i mean
it's in the case of the veronese it's a
little bit simpler because
you can look at the ideal of r inside
inside the projective space v
maybe i'm
just cheating but
of course you can repeat the definition
for i mean smoothable is a local
definition okay
so you can ask so for any other kind of
local
properties and this is
good for writing a lot of papers or if
you are old enough it's good for even
cases
but let me ask if you ever saw any
problem like that going the other
direction so asking that your
decal position as some global property
so for instance
one
one thing would be to ask for say that
this set of point is
arithmetically corresponding to say one
in that case you have probability that
you get some
say uh
vector bundle
and so you are asked in this case you
are this faffian staff
and you are asking that the linear space
is defined by puffins
in terms of the local coordinates of the
decomposition or things like that have
you ever been some what kind of what
[ __ ] stuff i understand i mean
if you ask something on the global
geometry of the
composition this means something on the
chord on the equations
of for instance
let's say that uh your x is a is a
surface
then asking that your the composition is
a medically guarded state this means
that you have a red to an arithmetically
called mcconaughey bundle
and on the surface and this means that
uh
every hypersurface container set of
point is defined in terms of fufiance
are the coordinates of your points so it
may be as some application to know that
your point is sits in a space that can
be defined by factor this is just a
rough idea no
reasonable way to do that but just
asking if you ever saw something
in the other direction so asking global
property of the decomposition instead of
local properties
i guess it's difficult to
track the global property yeah okay
that's
everything is difficult
and
the motivation
and the well i
this kind of problems are kind of in
some sense motivated by applications
whereas i don't see directs what you
invest
i mean
it is some
sort of not just saying that this is
you are something more too bright so
you are trying to
get a description of your object in
terms of
something which is lower to brag but i
don't know
i told you that was cheating
well
let's thank eric again